hi I'm Evangeline Lilly I'm Paul Rudd
I'm Hannah John Comyn I'm Hannah John
Carmen and we are doing the wired
autocomplete interview we live I'm
holding a sign for this wired interview
what is what is a Paul Rudd I wish I
knew what was Paul Rudd's first movie
Halloween six I can't believe I don't
know the full title what is Paul Rudd
credited an infinity war uh I I didn't
know that I was maybe the credit like my
role in infinity war is so small you
missed it what does Paul Rudd eat
oatmeal sometimes I love vegetables a
lot of a lot of almond eating going well
there was a specific kind of things when
I was doing this film so that I would
fit into the ant suit how to get Paul
Rudd hair I'll tell you the hairy one
you want Michael Douglas hair how did
Michael Douglas and Catherine zeta-jones
meet in Deauville France at the
Deauville Film Festival I was up there
with perfect murder
Catherine arrived with Zorro and I had
just seen Zorro when who is that lady
how old Michael Douglas father and my
father 102 in December I will was
Michael Douglas when he shot fatal
attraction that was 40 I wasn't born yet
[Laughter]
how tall is Michael Douglas I'm 5 feet
10 how is and Michael Douglas related to
Charlie Sheen we did a movie together
but I've never been anywhere near any of
it
how does ant-man become ant-man
and there was a man because of research
that I did on the quantum realm he also
stole his suit but he's not the real
ant-man no you're the I am and the end
then he is a fraud
how do ant-man powers work check out the
original I think it's available on DVD
how small just ant-man yet pretty small
how big can a man get a boat in your
bathtub
how does ant-man communicate with ants I
really think most of the answers are
gonna be found in the original film ants
talk have a group what's that they have
a group one they say ants what's in that
it what does ant-man mean by orange
slices I don't know when I was a kid at
halftime that's what we get because when
you get dried out your cramps you need
some citrus something it and it just
seemed like a funny thing to say what is
Evangeline Lilly doing now they can see
what you're doing what did Evangeline
Lilly do in lost I whined and complained
a lot I flirted with two different boys
a lot and I ran from a smoke monster an
awful lot what Evangeline means I once
deducted that my full name Nicole
Evangeline Lilly means victorious
evangelical Bride of Christ no pressure
how does Evangeline Lilly staying in
shape like everybody else I work out and
I eat good how to get Evangeline Lilly
hair you know what I think it is because
the commonality between us is we're both
of Irish descent you're Irish right who
looks like Evangeline Lilly just
recently I was mistaken for Julia
Roberts I also get Kate Beckinsale a lot
Hannah John Comyn cucumber I was in a
series written by Russell T Davies who
did queer as folk and the series is
called banana and cucumber and it was
the love story of me and Sean Hannity on
Carmen ghost I'm playing ghost in the
new ant-man and the wasp movie
hi John common Instagram Hannah
djk I've got peace yeah you got Facebook
Hannah John Comyn
ready player one I played a character
called finales and/or Steven Spielberg
was a delight and we would sing show
tunes in between say he does Hannah John
Comyn
Tomb Raider three movies coming out so
dream rate has already come out ready
play ones come out and the most was
coming out but Tomb Raider was the first
one to come out yeah yeah 2018
what made Paul Rudd what made me famous
all right what age was Paul Rudd and
clueless I think I was 24 what season of
friends is Paul Rudd in I came in on
season 9 I think and stuck around a
little bit for season 10 what up with
that Paul Rudd what up with that all
right what film is Paul Rudd watching in
role models was it like American me or
something what was Michael Douglas movie
my first movie was at him at 6 a.m.
what did Michael Douglas won an Oscar
for I think is what did Michael Douglas
win an Oscar for well depends which
Oscar you're talking about yeah I'll
give you the first one which was one
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
the other one was for Wall Street and
what is Michael Douglas September 25th
1944 I look pretty good going what is
Michael Douglas up to I'm up to sitting
here answer you stupid ask questions my
press junket for ant-man and the wasp
what is Michael Douglas will is my real
name is Evangeline Lilly in Lord of the
Rings no I'm not his Evangeline Lilly in
Game of Thrones nope I'm not is
Evangeline Lilly wearing a wig in
amen nope I'm not does Evangeline Lilly
speak French oui Geppetto say can
Evangeline be a boy's name
it's 2018 Evangeline can be anything you
want her to be his paul rudd from st.
Louis no I'm not he's Paul Rudd a rush
fan yeah my crush is Paul Rudd an
Orioles fan I'm a Royals fan they didn't
have a Royals uniform on the day we shot
that scene and knocked up is Paul Rudd
dead yes it is Paul Rudd going to be an
infinity War part 2 is that Paul Rudd
meme oh the Mark Ruffalo is that who is
the bad guy in ant-man and the wasp mmm
we have opponents but not necessarily
villains well I don't know there's uh
there's ghosts where did the wasp come
from from Michelle Pfeiffer's womb is
the wasp at man's wife in the comic
books yes in the movies yes if it's the
original one talking about yes and Hank
Pym but not me our wasp friendly or
wasps friendly to me yes they are is
wasp an insect
I don't know technically a wasp's inside
I think so yard insect bugs have six or
eight legs and they only have you know
they have eight legs and I think in six
ounce or less a man in the wasp when
does it take place it takes place in
theaters July 6